all right let's check out a sort of good
old-fashioned conspiracy theory this one
combines
the globalish you know how alex jones
always uses that term globalist
internationalist trotskyite socialist
shun like obama trudeau macron
and the rest of these zio beasts
that's a recording of me doing alex
jones okay so one american news oan
anchor allison steinberg
did a globalist rant about globalists
tracking her
through her apartments i guess it's a
nest thermostat
with its energy-saving settings
this is um yeah let's just take a look
at this and this is the level of
delusion that now is being uh that that
that we're now seeing presented in a
serious manner all right so i think it's
pretty obvious we can all agree the
whole goal with these globalists is to
track us and trace us and monitor every
single thing that we do in our everyday
lives in fact this device that you're
probably watching me from that you're
holding in your hand is doing just that
right now and we know this this is not
new news okay however i've just
discovered another layer of this that is
what i believe taking it a step
way too far so i just moved into this
new place and this nest device came
automatically installed uh oh
uh with the apartment it's the
thermostat control basically so it's
really cold in here because there's
cement floors and i
was constantly having to turn the heat
up
now
i realized
it would get cold after i turn the heat
up
this is this is just the best i hope you
guys see where this is going on multiple
occasions so i started thinking why is
this happening now get this i'm going to
show you the
interface of this and you're not going
to believe it okay so i'm having to turn
it up again because it went down to 70
and i wanted it at 73.
so it's having to heat up
again
so my old place when i when i lived in
boston my old place had these
and
when my tenants came in
the same thing happened and they didn't
ascribe it to the globalist they
ascribed it to the how the technology
works and i'll tell you how you fix this
this this is the best and because it
keeps turning itself back down and i was
wondering why is this happening well i
decided to go to
settings
and then i found this home away assist
then it says automatically use eco
temperatures when no one's home so that
means this thing
can track whether or not i'm in my
house yeah now
nest thermostats
they have a proximity sensor so like
when you walk by it
it turns on so you don't have to press
it like if you want to just see what the
temperature is you walk by and it senses
you walk by and it flips on and you go
oh it's 72 so you don't have to click it
or press it and it uses that to figure
out whether you're likely home or not
so this thing was turning itself off
when i wasn't home
and then would automatically start
reheating when it sensed i was back
inside it must be the globalist and if
that's not creepy enough they also
somehow now have my email address
because they keep harassing me in my
inbox to sign up for their stupid app so
it can connect to my phone their stupid
app can track me even further this is
absolute madness if you have an s turn
off all these settings because it's
taking it way too far yeah you can turn
off all of these settings i mean listen
uh at one point i started to suspect
that the milk frother attachment on my
espresso machine had a camera in it and
an rfid chip because every time i made
an espresso i would get an email
offering me a coffee based vaccine it
was crazy but then i realized no i'm
wrong i'm an idiot could she really
believe this all of these thermostats
have these functions
the thermostats
when i when i left my place in boston
and tenants came in
um i didn't use almost any of these
things
because i had turned them off i i like
to control everything manually you know
i'm like there's just types some people
are like set it to automatic and let it
do it thing in the car with climate
control i don't want to control the fan
speed and i just go i want 72
auto you figure out how to get us to
auto without a 72.
at home
i'm sort of more aware of like okay when
am i usually going to bed and i want it
cool or whatever so i turn all of this
stuff up this stuff off i don't want the
temperature changing when i'm in and out
i already am using more like
eco-friendly temperatures during the day
when i'm out at work you know all these
different things
so
when my tenants turned it on they were
like hey it's not doing anything and i
said well you've got to let it learn i
never used that so you've got to let it
learn your schedule
and it's a smart thermostat you just
turn it off there's no globalist
globalished yeah it's just the way the
technology's designed and i it's hard
for me to know for sure
whether what you just saw is serious i i
just don't know
it's very sick if it is
but maybe it's just trolling that's
allison steinberg from one american news
news network you can just turn all that
stuff off george soros won't have any
say
uh klaus schwab right because remember i
know her i know this is allison
steinberg so she may be jewish herself
i've never met anyone named steinberg
who's not jewish but globalish usually
is talking about rich jewish men who
want to control everything
including uh the fan speed apparently
now on your ac very wild stuff and my
question to you is simply
do you think she's for real
or do you think she's just playing this
up for her audience
when i'm looking for a good documentary
i'll sometimes scroll around on your
average streaming services and they're
okay but i almost always end up on an
app called curiositystream our sponsor
curiosity stream is the king of
documentaries they have only
documentaries i recently watched insect
apocalypse it is horrifying what's going
on with the bees extremely disturbing
but the documentary insect apocalypse is
fascinating and i can't recommend it
more highly there's a curiosity stream
app for all of your devices
curiositystream is always adding new
titles they have a ton of awesome
original content they have the big
award-winning documentaries by the
filmmakers we all know they also have
smaller independent documentaries that
are often just as good on every topic
under the sun and the best part about
curiosity stream is how affordable it is
you can get full access for 14.99 a year
not a month a year that's a buck 25 a
month when you go to curiositystream.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is in the description